you know um I told you in the email that
I felt bad when your book came up on the
show and I didn't know how to defend it
I didn't know what to do because I
didn't I was in that weird moment where
I was recommending it because I liked it
because I think it's a great book and he
was saying that just debunked well I
think you said you picked data yeah
right which is always weird well the
thing is any sort of popular non science
or nonfiction book is you have to choose
what data you're gonna include right I
mean there's an infinite amount of data
and so of course you form an argument
and then you present data that supports
your argument did you ever consider
arguing against herself
sure yeah yeah and in fact the book is
you know the book is written as an
argument against the standard narrative
so you know we had to present this and
what is the standard narrative who
believes this you know who thinks that
people evolved as monogamous and so we
quote quite heavily from those people
but you know the thing is I mean and I
really appreciated your email and I you
know we don't need to talk about this at
any length but it's not your job to
defend the book and it's not even my job
really to defend the book I think once a
book is out it's out right the book is
there you but isn't it it's not just the
book it's that when someone goes hard on
a book it's if they're doing it about
you as well expression of your work but
see that's the thing I don't accept that
Association and so if somebody wants to
critique the book that's totally cool
and and like look are there things that
we may have misunderstood of course are
the things we left out of course there
are you know mistakes of course you know
that's right there's you're human you
made it right there are hundreds of
citations in that book now if somebody
says as people have like you know Chris
Ryan you know deliberately
misrepresented the science or doesn't
understand the first thing about
evolution or you know whatever it is I
just don't engage because
that's emotional it's like we were
saying earlier about comments online I
think people react to sexathon very
emotionally right and so if they're
reacting emotionally there's no point in
me engaging with them because they're
expressing some something that's going
on in their lives that I don't know
anything about and I don't they're
suffering in some way I'm not talking
about Brett Weinstein or anybody
specifically but there's an emotional
reason to have that kind of reaction
whereas if somebody says look on page
you know 72 you said that bonobos are
the only ape that does this and the
actually Gibbons do it as well okay we
can talk about that you know that's
that's factual
Brian so when people say oh it's
cherry-picked well which cherries what
are you talking about right you know a
specific thing and gets wrong with it
right right instead of saying it's
cherry-picking his vast general credit
critique of the book like well right and
if it gets about me right like oh that's
because he wants to get laid or that was
one of the art was that it would be a
good book to write I think I don't
remember if he said or if his wife said
that it would be a good book and I
really love those two they're great
they're cool I just think when it comes
to monogamy and sexuality people have a
notion in their head and that notion
almost always aligns with how they're
living their life or how they wish they
were living their lives yeah maybe
and again we're not talking about
specifically I never met them I know
they're a great couple they're wonderful
people but I mean there's there's
something about the subject of your book
I think I told you this before without
mating naming names my friend brought
your book home and his wife threw it
away yeah you and I talked about that on
the very first podcast actually yeah
yeah into this a lot right you can
imagine cocktail parties with me can get
awkward very quickly know for sure you
know because people ask oh wait you're
the guy yeah you know and then often
you'll see some people are very eager to
hear about it and talk about it and
other people are just these steams
coming out of their ears right I think
you know a lot of people are in
relationships that they're trying to
make fit into
ooh what they believe is the right way
to have a relationship and often it just
doesn't it doesn't work right and so
there's a lot of shame and regret and
resentment and all kinds of negative
energy around that and so any discussion
where you're saying well maybe that's
not actually the way it's meant to work
for some people that's an incredibly
liberating message for other people it's
extremely threatening right and I
understand that and and you know so I've
become very emotionally sort of separate
from the book it's out there it stands
or not based on its merits I don't when
people get all riled up I've learned to
just be like yeah you know what that's
fine that's between you and a book
that's a very healthy approach good for
you
it's just to me it seems like people
that get most have said about it don't
get most upset about it for rational
reason they get upset about it because
it challenges the way they live their
life well